let's have you uh tapped in without yet
Alchemist ow yo unheard story right here
unheard story nobody knows this story
[Music]
to go
I [__] go to Al's crib
pick out a Beat
write it right there on the spot as I'm
writing the first verse
West Side gun comes in big body best is
already there
uh that's gotta be a cool hangout you
and big body best in the same place oh
my God yo [__]
[__] Conway comes in so I'm in I'm in
there's a center like the island in the
kitchen I'm writing it but these
[__] is having wild
conversations I got some other [__] on
my mind that just happened that same day
where I was like I really don't not in
the mood to write but I wrote These two
verses I put it on the beat
we did it after the next day both of us
hit each other was like um I think we
could do something better and I was like
yeah I think we could do something
better too yeah so let's just scrap it
and that's the only time I ever worked
The Alchemist and I'm so tight that that
happened because Alchemist is like one
of my favorites one of the girls
producers and I'm just it just was like
a [__] tornado of [__] that was going
on in my life and literally right there
while I was writing that just took me
off my game where I was just like we
could do better situation up yeah if you
and big body vests are in the same place
is it like just like an aggravated
assault felony charge like in the air
absolutely just floating around
absolutely that that same time I think
the next day me and him went drove to
Vegas together and just oh my God out to
Vegas Vegas with you two would be it
because you're sober now yo but like
you're also you yeah yeah facts I would
just be like yo can we go [__] with
prostitutes like you know my favorite
thing to do in Vegas is like because I
used to live there
like you know I'd like just I like to
embarrass old men with their horse
so like uh like I like walk up to like a
dude who's like with like you know
obvious prostitute you know like I'm
like GFE get the GFE going huh
girlfriend experience
[Laughter]
shout out to Backpage those were the
days a hundred roses ah
um what for you this album is all you
also have you I feel like you're a
pretty vulnerable guy in terms of like a
lot of people know a lot about like a
lot of low points in your life a lot of
you know your battles of addiction and
obviously being incarcerated but on this
album you kind of shared a little bit
about your family life yeah your pops
pass away from AIDS yeah HIV he had
contract he contracted HIV from Needles
needles yeah yeah yeah luckily me and my
moms didn't get it
um and yeah passed away when I was four
years old damn and that was probably I
mean I know you talk about kind of like
having a hard time forgiving him
yeah nah that was that was I said that
was gone okay okay Pops I don't really
have that man I have like two three
memories about my father and one of them
is like etched in my mind it's like like
a movie scene now in my mind when I
think about it I remember walking
through the the funeral the the funeral
home my mother bringing me by the hand
and kissing them on his forehead in this
casket that's like one of the only
memories I have in my [__] yeah yeah
facts that's crazy so yeah yeah that
happens and you're kind of like forced
to like grow up and be like that'll be a
gotta be the man of the house from early
you know what I'm saying so it is what
it is these things make me who I am you
know yeah 100 man and like you know
adversity and like you said man like and
I'm not the only one that goes through
it so when you push it like that on song
there's nine billion people on this
Earth at least 900 million have gone
through the same exact thing or
something even similar nah some people
that's what I'm saying that's like the
kind of [__] where like you put that on
like a record and you're like oh man
this is gonna cut through to people
because you do like your [__] like where
you're talking about people having
um feminine benses you know what I'm
saying the C classes but then you also
if you have a record like that it's like
yo man I also like want y'all to like
really sit here with me and like you
know that's some [__] to live to bro I
mean why did why did why do we love
artists like you ain't get it no
why do we love artists like DMX why do
we love artists like Eminem because they
show the vulnerable side there's a
strength and vulnerability 100 you know
what I'm saying and and that those type
of songs and that type of music connects
with people on such a different level
and it becomes and it's Timeless right
right like I could rap about the
feminine bands and then smacking your
moms and punting your daughter but it's
cold for a minute it might wear out but
when you talk about real [__]
it's Timeless 100 percent